A FEDERAL JUDGE BLOCKED
CALIFORNIA'S LAW REQUIRING THE
PRESIDENT TO RELEASE HIS TAX
RETURNS TO APPEAR ON THE BALLOT.
HERE WITH REACTION THE
PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY JAY SEKULO
JAY SEKULOW.
THE BIGGER PICTURE IS, WE HAVE A
REAL COLLUSION UNCOVERED, A REAL
QUID PRO QUO AND ONCE AGAIN IT'S
A BOOMERANG.
>> THIS IS THE ONGOING PATTERN
AND PRACTICE OF TRYING TO SHRED
THE CONSTITUTION.
WHAT CALIFORNIA TRIED TO DO WAS
ADD A REQUIREMENT TO THE
CONSTITUTION SO THAT IF YOU
DIDN'T PRODUCE YOUR TAX RETURNS
YOU DO NOT APPEAR ON THE BALLOT.
WE CHALLENGE THAT IN FEDERAL
COURT.
THE COURT INDICATED LAST WEEK
THEY WERE LIKELY TO RULE IN OUR
FAVOR, THE RULING JUST CAME DOW
DOWN.
IT IS DECLARED UNCONSTITUTIONAL,
IT VIOLATES THE FREEDOM OF
ASSOCIATION, THE PRESIDENTIAL
QUALIFICATION CLAUSE, AND EQUAL
PROTECTIONS OF THE LAW.
THE COURT ISSUED THE FOLLOWING
ORDER, THE DEFENDANT ARE
ENJOINED FROM ENFORCING
PROVISIONS ON THE PRESIDENTIAL
TAX, THE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT, REQUIRING
CANDIDATES TO DISCLOSE THEIR TAX
RETURNS AS A CONDITION OF
APPEARING.
I WILL TIE THIS INTO WHAT YOU
HAD MENTIONED IN YOUR MONOLOGUE.
THAT IS THE ISSUE OF THE
PRESIDENT CALLING HEADS OF STATE
REGARDING THIS ONGOING
INVESTIGATION OF HOW THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE MATTER -- AS
JAMES COMEY SHOULD'VE CALLED IT
BASED ON HIS PREVIOUS
STATEMENTS -- HOW THAT STARTED.
HERE'S WHAT WE HAVE.
MY COLLEAGUE PROFESSOR HARRY
HUTCHISON WHO IS A SENIOR POLICY
ANALYST FOR THE AMERICAN CENTER
FOR LAW AND JUSTICE PRODUCED A
DOCUMENT WHICH REFERENCES TWO
TREATIES.
THIS ONE IS WITH AUSTRALIA, THIS
ONE IS WITH UKRAINE.
TREATY WITH UKRAINE, A MUTUAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE IN CRIMINAL
MATTERS, SAME WITH THE MATTER
INVOLVING AUSTRALIA.
THE PRESIDENT, WHEN HE MADE
CALLS ON BEHALF OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO ENCOURAGE
COOPERATION REGARDING HOW THIS
ENTIRE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE FRAUD
TOOK PLACE, HE WAS NOT ONLY
WITHIN HIS CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
TO DO IT BUT AS HARRY HUTCHISON
POINTS OUT, IT WAS HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION TO
ENGAGE IN THIS -- WHY?
HE IS REQUIRED TO FAITHFULLY
EXECUTE THE LAWS OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION.
THAT'S WHAT HE IS DOING.
WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IS
INDIVIDUALS -- AND THIS IS WHAT
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND.
THOSE WHO ARE SO OPPOSED TO WHAT
THE PRESIDENT IS DOING ON ANY
FRONT ARE TRYING TO WEAPONIZE
THE CONSTITUTION TO MAKE THE
EXECUTION OF IT ILLEGAL.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE TWO
TREATIES AND THERE ARE OTHER
TREATIES WITH OTHER COUNTRIES AS
WELL -- WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
PHONE CALLS IN THE HISTORY OF
WHAT HAS HAPPENED HERE, FIRST IT
WAS QUID PRO QUO -- THEN THEY
LOOK AT THE TRANSCRIPT, NO QUID
PRO QUO.
THEN IT WAS THE PRESIDENT IS
ASKING FOR INQUIRIES TO BE MADE
ON VARIOUS MATTERS -- I GUESS
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO THAT
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION.
ACCORDING TO THESE TREATIES
WHICH IS NOW AN OBLIGATION.
THEN IT WAS A COVER-UP -- A
COVER-UP OF WHAT?
THE DOCUMENT WAS RELEASED.
AT THE END OF THIS, WHERE IT
SITS RIGHT NOW, NOT ONLY DID WE
WIN IN CALIFORNIA AND WE WILL
WIN ALL OF THIS NONSENSE AS WELL
BUT WHAT IS AT STAKE FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IS THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION.
THAT IS WHAT IS AT STAKE HERE.